all right elizabeth
yes elizabeth uh where did you grow up
where you from originally
olive branch mississippi and tell me
about your childhood you had both your
parents when you were young
um i did to start off with
my dad left you know when i was around
two or three four or five i guess
he kept coming around for a little bit
and
i was actually molested by my dad from
about
three to six i'm sorry
um other than that i had a
my mom she's a nurse i had a good
childhood
i was raised you know my mom and my
grandparents
um things were pretty good pretty normal
you know other than my dad and then he
left
and stayed gone you know
[Music]
i still to this day don't see him
you know very often um
i remember like riding foilers you know
and just grew up out in the country
everything normal
i went to school everything was good
but i always remember feeling like i
wasn't enough
it wasn't did you have that feeling
before you were
raped molested or did it start after
that i think it started after that
morning
more when i grew into my teenage years
yeah
did you ever confront your dad or say
anything to your mom or anybody
i did to my mom when i was 18 and you
know
she didn't know i mean and you know by
then
my thing is i don't live to hate anybody
so i don't need him they forgive him i
have to remember he's sick too
yeah especially with me being out in
this like
i know that you know we all deal with
some kind of demons
yeah and then how far did you go in
school
i went to my 11th grade year i dropped
out
and then i got a ged and i did a year of
college
a year of nursing school actually and
then
i had my first son which is landon
and uh i wanted to stay at home with him
so i stayed at home with him his dad was
a plumber
you know and um he took care of
everything
even though we did drugs i stayed at
home with my child and did them
you know i know that sounds horrible but
that's how do drugs come into your life
um
i think being around the wrong people
you know
the people your mom and them tell you to
stay away from
you know
they were older than me and they were
doing something
and i wanted to know what it was like
yeah
did you did you find that the drugs kind
of
numb the pain of of what you went
through as a child
they do they do it numbs every
well it did and numb to everything made
everything okay
it made everything okay made everything
normal
everybody was happy or i was happy you
know i thought
that yeah in reality it's
it's miserable yeah emotional and then
how did uh prostitution come into your
life
um um i've always had my son's dad to
take care of me and to take care of
everything
right at two years ago he passed away
from an overdose and um
that's when i actually started
prostitution
because you needed the money because i
needed the money to support my habit
and your son well
in actuality i don't take care of my son
oh where is he
he's with my mom
sorry it's okay
and i don't talk about that sorry
so sex work started for you and you
worked on your own or with a pimp
i started with a pant um
and i saw that i was giving these people
way more money than
what i was getting out of it i mean i
wasn't getting
literally anything but drugs that wasn't
being taken care of in any type of way
you know you were still struggling by
myself so
i decided i was going to go struggle by
myself
and not come into midtown
and um i
just started on my own but you still
you still have to pay for protection you
know
you have to have a place to stay every
night
you know were you able to get away from
that pimp relationship
i was it was actually um
he he still to this day i deal with him
and i still have to pay him when i see
him and stuff
but i was actually able to leave
how did you do that i just walked away
one day
and you know i got
uh i was um
kidnapped over it and uh
braved and beat and
after that nothing you know but you
still continue to pay him today
just just because you're in his
territory or
when i'm in his territory yes
and the guys that
your customers the guys that pay you
they
they treat you nicely they're
how do you get treated by them most of
them do
um you know you have some
that um they take advantage of this
situation they will rape you they will
take your money
you know um
do you get depressed sometimes till i
get depressed
i stay depressed yeah
and that's why i still you know i do the
heroin now because my body physically
has to have it
but it's like
the more i do the more miserable i am
you know it's like it's a never-ending
cycle of just madness
and are you are you making enough money
to support
yourself or your habits um
most of the time i do sometimes i don't
you know sometimes i don't have a place
to stay
sometimes i don't have all the dough
that i need to keep me well through the
day
i mean just it depends
i do pretty well you know most of the
time
and do you still have contact with your
family i do
i do they know what you're going through
and yeah
um well i mean they they know
but we don't talk about it like
you know it was always in my household
when there's a problem you push it under
the rug and
it just goes away but this is
not going away you know
this is real true life do you see a way
out
right now honestly no
and so you have one child right i have
two children i have a 19 month old
that was adopted by a family in memphis
and who is the father of your second
child
he used to be a customer man and
we actually got into a relationship
and but it
it was just not not a good situation
you know very bad enabler
very controlling you know
in one form or another i'm always
getting
beat on or raped or you know
just it must be hard because everyone in
your life is trying to take advantage of
you
that's how yes that's how it is using
you one way or another
and that's going to undermine your
self-worth
on top of what you've already went
through as a young girl right
what helps you survive this do what you
must be very strong
to to continue doing this
what helps you survive it
i honestly don't know the thought
of my child living with no parents
that's my only thing
i mean because i still see him and stuff
you know just about every weekend
but just the thought of you know losing
his dad
was enough what if he lost both of us
but if i don't get off of this he you
know
he might as well not have me because i'm
not there
you've been arrested before um
yes once for diva
other than that i'd try to stay out of
the way
i respect the i respect them they have a
job to do
and that's what they're doing and i'm
doing something wrong
how much do you make in a day
anywhere from
250 to 1500
and if that 15 on a good night you're
making 1500 you end up keeping how much
of that
i mean what do you mean after you're
giving away some of it to the
tim i mean i don't go give him
a say out of 1500 he might get two
yeah so that's fairly good money on a
good night yeah
and yet you're still struggling i mean
i have a 300 a day dope have it
almost yeah right at it
that means i keep that up and then
you know um
a place to live you know food
you know some days we go without eating
some days i don't make anything
if i don't feel you know i don't make
anything
how do you feel like this has changed
you this life
working the streets and i feel like it
has broke me as a person
i feel less than even more than
i did before um
i feel very um
i feel like i'm in just existing in this
world
how do you feel about the the men that
they pay you
do you respect them are they good guys
are you just
i just do my job you're just using them
and they're using you
right
what what advice would you give to
someone else that's in your situation
and considering doing this kind of work
don't don't
um anything
anything has to be better than this like
i mean what comes along with it the
abuse
you know when i was directly with the
pimp if i would have made fifteen
hundred dollars i would have to take it
directly to him
all of it all of it right now
you know um
don't that's that's all i'm saying is
don't
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
um
i think to watch out for yourself
because nobody's gonna watch out for you
like you
never value your family
how old are you i'm 30.
what's your biggest regret losing your
kids
yes but i have two actually
my son's dad doing dying due to
drugs you know i wish i hadn't been
there i wished i could have
stopped having to get
my child up for adoption yeah it's going
to be so hard for
my mother right
and my other son him having you know
losing his dad
and me being out here
do you feel like the the sexual abuse as
a child kind of
set the whole chain of destruction
got that started for you led to the drug
addiction led to the
sex work led to the situation you're in
right now
maybe some of it or maybe me not dealing
with it
you know did yeah it's a lot to deal
with you know they
they tried to work me through it when i
was younger
and i think if i would have done it you
know
maybe you think therapy might have
helped maybe yeah
yeah if i would have took heat in
actually
you know stuck with it and not let that
make me as a person because that's not
who i am that's just what i've been
through
all right elizabeth well thank you so
much for sharing your story
and i wish you the best of luck with
with everything you're going through
thank you thank you very much
you